let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy
happy hump day
today's wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern you know what time
that is it's time for let's talk the
tony michaels podcast hello everyone
i'm the tony michaels
and boy do we have some stuff to talk
about
today
a lot of stuff happening in the last
week but yesterday yesterday we finally
got some movement
on mr sloppy steve bannon
being held in criminal contempt it seems
as if we're going to get a vote very
soon on the house floor it took long
enough
but we're going to have some clips here
um from the the
the committee hearing last night from
the chairman benny thompson and also the
co-chair
liz cheney
uh darth vader jr liz chaney will be
will be blessing us with her clip today
i streamed it live last night on twitch
and on twitter if you guys want to go
check it out you can actually see the
whole the whole thing
on the twitch account or on twitter
and i also post it on the youtube
account so go check that out if you want
to if you want to see the entire hearing
it is over on the youtube channel it's
on twitch and on twitter uh the the
easiest place to find it is probably the
youtube channel while you're there on
the youtube channel while you're there
go ahead and subscribe
to the youtube channel because we have a
lot of changes coming in several weeks i
was supposed to have a guest this friday
but we will not have the guest this
friday it'll probably be next friday we
will announce who that guest will be
next wednesday i'm very excited to have
her on our show uh anybody out there
that's on left-leaning political
tick-tock or if he
or if you're a maga trump bumper you
definitely will know who she is uh
because you will either love her or you
will hate her if you're maga if your
manga you will hate her
that's why i want to have her on
um and everyone loves her on tick tock
um
you'll know who it is if you're on
tiktok and if you're not on tik tok uh
probably if you're on instagram you'll
know who it is as well but we will we
will announce that next week i'm gonna
hold it close to the vest here uh we
were supposed to have her on this friday
but our schedules could not meet to do
the recording of the special special
guest episode but next week we hope to
have her on on friday so thanks for
tuning in next week on friday because i
know you will i know you will and and
remember you can watch you can watch the
podcast on youtube twitter twitch live
every wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern write like we are
right now or you can go download
the podcast if you don't want to watch
my beautiful face you just want to hear
my beautiful voice you can download the
podcast on all your favorite directories
so let's get back to the news
mr steve bannon
uh is going to there's going to be a
vote to hold him in contempt so we're
going to talk about that today i
probably will talk about that near the
end i want to save that for the last
punch
right because you know steve bannon
right now has one of the most punchable
faces i believe maybe in the entire
country it's possible allegedly
allegedly people calm down allegedly
there are a lot of people out there
with some very very very
very punchable faces but here here's
what i'll also tell you another person
uh that is uh in that in that categories
travis trit have you heard this travis
tritt's uh self-canceling himself or
some [ __ ] uh so we'll talk about that
for just a few minutes because that's
all travis tritt deserves i'm just
trying to get banned by travis tritt
because what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
cut this clip
from the podcast when i absolutely
eviscerate him here and then i'm gonna
cut it post it on twitter and i'm gonna
tag him because i want to be banned by i
feel like i'm out of the loop he's
banned everyone but me like the entire
universe is banned i mean besides your
manga trump pumping queueing on spread
necks you know they got to go somewhere
to get their misinformation and you know
they think travis tritt is some kind of
medical expert or something i guess the
mullet does it for him i don't know
but
i
my goal here today is to get banned
or for travis trick to block me not ban
me block me cancel me i want him to
cancel me on twitter so we're gonna do a
little rant i'll cut it up i'll post it
on twitter you guys go nuts over tag him
tag him tag him i'm gonna tag him later
on uh because that's the goal here is to
get blocked by travis trid some other
stuff that's in the news is uh nicholas
cruz the
the young the young murderer
pleads guilty to 17 counts of murder in
the massacre of the marjory uh the
stoneman douglas high school in parkland
florida you remember this several years
ago he murdered 17 people
and
in a mass shooting in a school and today
he pled guilty in court and he gave a
really really pathetic
uh plea for
for mercy it was absolutely pathetic so
we'll talk about that the other thing
that we're going to talk about which is
very very very important when it comes
to all these investigations that are
happening uh around the cheeto dust
mobster uh the russian oligarch
darapaska that's hard for me to say it
again dara pasco was raided by the fdi
two homes he had two houses that was
rated and he gets pissed off about it so
we'll talk about that today too and then
again at the end we're gonna talk about
steve bannon
so stay tuned because we're gonna play
some clips of the uh the select
committee of last night of the hearing
where they voted uh to move the vote to
the floor
to hold steve bannon in contempt
but let's talk about the first ship bag
travis tritt
let's see if we can get blocked here so
travis tritt decides that he's gonna
cancel all his shows at all these venues
where they require vaccine passports and
they require mask
well very nice travis very nice i am
super super excited that you're doing
this number one because your infested
ass isn't running around spreading covet
uh at on at venues because we know
you're not vaccinated and that's really
the point here is travis tripp the only
reason why he's cancelling shows he's
not canceling these shows the [ __ ]
venues are cancelling the shows they're
not letting anyone in that that doesn't
have a vaccine passport
and travis tritt that ivermecton paste
horse paste eaten [ __ ]
definitely does not have a [ __ ]
passport because he [ __ ] believes
people like tucker carlson
and sean hannity and all these [ __ ]
people on fox news who are vaccinated
they're [ __ ] vaccinated telling
people not to get vaccinated it's a
travis trit is a [ __ ] q anon manga
trump bumper spread nick
[ __ ] spread nick
and that's why that's why he's getting
his shows canceled ain't because travis
tritt wants to cancel him
think about this think about the phone
call
travis calls up to the venue the venue's
like hey travis we can't let anyone in
that's not vaccinating and he's like
what do you mean well he can't let
anyone in that's not vaccinated he says
well me and my entire band aren't
vaccinated they're like
you can't come in our building
well how the hell is travis tritt gonna
do a [ __ ] country music show if him
and his entire [ __ ] band can't enter
the [ __ ] building think about it
travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting cancelled by the [ __ ]
venues who are like nah
no no one can come in you can't come in
without a vaccine passport you or anyone
else dumb [ __ ]
that travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting his shows cancelled cause
he's a [ __ ] bonehead
that's why this isn't him choosing
other than the venues that he chose
decided not to let people who you don't
have vaccine passports which he doesn't
have all he's got is this little
ivermectin prescription drug
from the online ivermectin store down in
florida we've seen this
we've seen this he must be he must be
the grand dragon of the ivermectin
institute on facebook
the ivermectin instant i'm sure they
have like a hierarchy
i mean you know they probably have you
know
cult leaders inside the cult
right i'm sure there's like there's like
moderators am i wrong
i mean maybe maybe not i mean maybe
that's why facebook's changing their
name to the facebook because they're
trying to rebrand because they got all
these problems with these ivermectin
groups
because that's where a lot of the hate
and misinformation is being spread
around because
because there's one thing these
politicians know these right-wing
[ __ ] out there that are already
vaccinated that are telling people not
to get vaccinated and bringing people on
tv shows like travis tritt as if he's
some kind of [ __ ] medical expert
to [ __ ] speak about vaccines of
vaccine passports and freedom
there's one thing that they know to keep
this pandemic going was keep trumpism
going it divides the country oh that's
good for trumpism because because we
know that that trumpism is fascism in a
maga hat
we know that and without the pandemic
without this division of oh i'm gonna
cancel my shows when he's actually
getting cancelled
he's actually getting canceled
he didn't cancel his shows the venue did
because him and his band don't have
vaccine passports
that's why
they wouldn't why would they let them in
the building and
why would they not let patrons in the
building that didn't have vaccine
passports but what [ __ ] travis tritt
and his entire band stand on stage and
they not have vaccine passports huh
that seems fair right get the [ __ ] out
of here
get the [ __ ] out of
here and you notice that that the
pandemic is starting to come
to a to a certain type of end here now
we'll probably have more uh a
fluctuation up in the holidays that's
kind of what the experts are saying i
expect to see an uptick because
everyone's going to gather up but more
and more people with the mandates boy
they're getting vaccinated they're
getting vaccinated or they're quitting
their jobs and they're staying at home
which is good for all of us
yeah you and you nasty infected
[ __ ] you don't want to get
vaccinated oh you don't want to you
don't want to play with the mandates
fine
quit your job and stay the [ __ ] home
congratulations you helped us with the
pandemic
so [ __ ] travis tritt and anyone who
looks like travis tritt [ __ ] him
all right so i hope that i hope that
clip and we'll clip that out of the
podcast and we'll post that on twitter
and i'll tag him and then you guys can
go and comment and tag him too hopefully
hopefully it will trigger mr travis
tritt
to block me because i'm not blocked by
him yet hell i might already be blocked
by him now just by
doing the podcast i i think he has you
know it's got to be where
uh travis tritt has a full-time staff
you cannot [ __ ] block that many
people without having a full-time staff
blocking people i mean you just block
block block block because it can't be
just on twitter he's got to be blocking
people all over the [ __ ] all over
social media he's gotta have four or
five people blocking constantly 24 hours
a day it's [ __ ] crazy and i'm not
blocked yet i'm [ __ ] disappointed and
i feel left out
so let's let's get travis trit to block
me
the next story in the news is uh this
nicholas cruz story as you guys
know
uh nicholas cruz is the mass murderer
the school shooter down at marjory
stoneman douglas high school in parkland
florida where he killed 17 people um he
pled guilty today the seven those 17
counts of murder he gave a really
[ __ ] pathetic
uh uh a mercy plea
as he's trying to plea for his life
because they're gonna decide whether
this this
this [ __ ] idiot gets the the death
penalty or he gets life in prison now
i'm against the death penalty
and i i don't care what the circumstance
i i don't think that it makes us any
better if we kill him because he killed
17 people
and you know that's just me
life in prison really does uh
some work on some people and and we
should do some prison reform where we're
putting dangerous [ __ ] like
this nicholas cruz in prison for life
and people who are non-violent out of
the [ __ ] leave leave more room
and unless we don't have to spend as
much money on non-violent people
but someone like like this cruise
character who murdered 17 people at a
high school
with a semi-automatic rifle because he
had access to one
because we can't get people to get off
their [ __ ] ass and do the right thing
and keep guns at the hands of people who
who should not have them
and reduce gun violence and gun death in
this country
i mean not not only does he give some
stupid plea about drugs he's talking
about how how drugs are the problem and
they create hatred and violence in this
country or some [ __ ] well this
[ __ ] was on all his social media
with a maga hat on and make america
great again he was a he's a [ __ ]
trump hunter humper
and he's trying to he's trying in his
apology and his plea to not have the
death penalty
uh where he's he and then this is the
purpose of it i mean this is an attempt
by him pleading guilty this is an
attempt to avoid the death penalty
that's that's what him and his i'm sure
his legal counsel is betting on here is
that this this guilty plea will allow
him to get the golden ticket for for
life uh without parole as opposed to the
death penalty uh for the 17 counts now
uh as as far as
this [ __ ] bs victim mentality that he
has like in this in this in the goddamn
thing he acts like oh he's the [ __ ]
victim here i was victimized
but no you you you're pleading guilty to
murdering
people in a school shooting
you you [ __ ] maniac
so this only this only proves that mr
cruz
is not rehabilitated at in the say the
least that he's only he's only doing
this and he's only pleading guilty to
save his own goddamn skin from the death
penalty
which i guess i guess that is one thing
that the death penalty might yield
is the possibility of someone pleading
guilty in court so the families of these
victims don't have to go through the
whole process of them acting like
they're [ __ ] innocent when everyone
knows everyone knows that this person
did what they did it's not it's not
[ __ ] rocket science it's not like the
public doesn't know that he went into
the school and murdered these people
it's not like you know they found a dead
body and they gotta [ __ ] discover who
did it and present evidence that's not
the case
so maybe just maybe the the only good
thing that could yield from the death
penalty is the scare of it to make
someone like this
plea guilty in court to spare the
[ __ ] victims to get justice and spare
the [ __ ] victims families
and the people that they leave behind
so
my feeling of it is the statement that
he gave which it was probably less than
a minute it was all bs again it was some
it was some victim mentality statement
that someone uh wrote up it sounded like
there was a hundred rewrites of this
thing so it didn't sound too much like
he was a god that he was the goddamn
victim because his legal team is trying
to get him off the death penalty here
they're trying to get him in life
without parole
so there there's that in the news and
really honestly uh uh everyone should be
uh voicing their opinion about this
and uh speaking about the death penalty
and
what
because that that's the conversation
that we need to have around this we we
do not need to have the conversation
rather whether this guy's innocent or
his [ __ ] statement with some kind of
hero thing [ __ ] that [ __ ]
uh we we need to discuss the death
penalty because that's a real [ __ ]
problem that we have in this country is
killing innocent people not people like
nick cruz who we know we know
he's [ __ ] guilty uh again maybe maybe
that's one good thing that the death
penalty yields is the fear that you'll
have to go to the to the uh to be put to
death so you'll plea guilty to spare
everyone the [ __ ]
of that i'm innocent
because we know you're not
so the next story and
we're gonna go uh on to the next story
and this one's gonna take just a little
bit and then we're going to get to the
steve bannon story and that one's going
to take a little bit too
the next story
it happened yesterday
and it didn't get a lot of attention
other than from the person who got
raided uh i know i don't know yet maybe
you guys remember um there was a guy
named i know what was his name he was a
manager of someone's campaign
i think he actually went to prison and
he had something to do with like
ukrainians and russians um i think his
name was paul manafort yeah that was his
name he who was he the campaign manager
for who was that guy the campaign
manager for do you guys remember
i think i think he was a campaign
manager for the cheeto dust mobster in
2016.
i i remember very very clearly him being
at the republican national convention
on tv racking it up minute after minute
after minute giving his take on what
donald trump was going to be you
remember the speech where he came out
and said i alone can fix it right and
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you fixed a lot
you did you sure did fix it you [ __ ]
idiot
but paul manafort was on tv the whole
time as the campaign manager
and you remember paul manafort after the
convention kind of slightly walked away
from from the campaign and then steve
bannon stepped in
wait us wait a second
wait a second wait us those both of
those names are in the news huh
huh isn't that kind of convenient isn't
that kind of convenient
that that paul manafort a russian
oligarch got his house rated who paul
manafort used to work for
and paul manafort was the campaign
manager
on the 2016 trump campaign and after he
left because you know reasons unknown
maybe like criming was going to be
discovered steve bannon steps in
steve bannon where do we know that name
from that sounds [ __ ] familiar it's
almost like yesterday there was a
hearing
to push forward a vote on the house
floor
to hold steve bannon sloppy steve in
criminal contempt of congress
which will certainly be voted on and
pushed to the department of justice
which we're going to talk about here in
a little bit but don't you find it funny
how those two stories are in the news
almost in the same god damn day actually
in the exact same day
and how the dots connect in this in this
trump color book
what do you guys think do you think if
trump i mean i don't want him to get a
presidential library but do you think a
coloring book factory
qualifies
as a presidential library i don't know
maybe it's a question we should ask i
mean i'm you know
maybe it's a color book collection i
don't know but the dots in the trump
color book really seem to go together
really good and they kind of when you
put them all together it spells out
guilty
because we're gonna watch a few clips
from that select committee but paul
manafort and
steve bannon have
connections here there's dots here that
go back to the russian oligarch
all like daraposka who was raided by the
fbi yesterday his home in washington dc
was raided and he also had a home in
greenwich village in new york city that
was also raided
now
supposedly supposedly in statements that
daraposka puts out that oh my god these
homes aren't owned by me they're owned
by relatives right well yeah of course
they are
i mean
someone who's [ __ ] sanctioned by the
treasury of the united states isn't
exactly gonna put property in their own
[ __ ] name that's not how uh russian
money laundering alert works just go ask
grandpa poopypants
oh i mean why do you think he he [ __ ]
buries all his businesses and a hundred
different levels of llc's and delaware
llcs so no one knows who the [ __ ] it is
i don't own anything it's not me i don't
own anything
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] rich people
trick where they don't own [ __ ] they
don't own houses they don't own
businesses they don't own anything but
sometimes somehow they're filthy [ __ ]
rich
hmm i wonder so of course the [ __ ]
houses that he has are in other people's
names
of course they are a [ __ ] of course
they are
but the the i i don't know there's two
things that that i think are the best
part about this uh there's two they're
they're on the same level here
uh two things that i noticed about this
this raid
one is derapaska's statement and on
social media he was [ __ ] pissed
absolutely [ __ ] pissed
about the the fbi raiding his homes uh
he he claimed that they were empty and
they were vacant and abandoned that's
what the the word they used was
abandoned i guess i don't know i guess
that may have been the translation
was abandoned you know like like they
were empty but he he's mad that they
took all his his good stuff like the
alcohol and all the [ __ ]
so in other words the these aren't
really homes where he he lives these are
these are probably [ __ ] money
laundering schemes and the reason why
you wonder about it is because they they
claim this is uh a raid due to the
sanctions
you know um because of the 2016 election
and and several other reasons uh oscar
deripaska has had sanctions placed
against him from the united states and
that was one reason why i was like what
the [ __ ]
i mean you would think you would think
that uh russian oligarch who has
financial sanctions against them from
the united states would not allowed to
be in the united states and would not
allow to be able to own property in the
united states
i mean shouldn't we deport this person
or seize their property shouldn't we do
that if they have financial financial
sanctions from this
the treasury department
isn't that a thing i mean jesus christ
we have we have we have families of
people
who who work hard
and and
work in menial jobs farm jobs picking
the food that americans eat
working their hands to the bone and we
well we should deport them
well they [ __ ] pick the food that you
eat you [ __ ]
and they do the jobs that you don't want
to do you know you're complaining about
oh there's help on it signs everywhere
everyone's so lazy everyone's so lazy
well then what are you complaining about
people coming here and wanting jobs for
regardless of their legal status you
[ __ ] idiots
but here is here's mr rich dude russian
oligarch
the [ __ ] oil tycoon billionaire
putin's puppy
daraposca gets to own property and you
know do whatever he wants have abandoned
houses the united states and relatives
names
i think i think our aim
our aim is a little wrong in this
country and we need to we need to change
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] cult-like
[ __ ] where they're they're looking up to
putin and russians
i mean how could you see this any other
way
well
if you're in a cult you do see it that
way
the other part that i found
completely hilarious about the raid is
uh
is they seized a car and it to me not in
the picture and i don't know if it's
real i don't give a [ __ ] if it's real i
don't really care i'm just throwing
around ideas here
if
the car was seized
well if it's a financial crime why is
the car seized i'm not sure why you
would see someone's car like is there
physical evidence in the car or
something
like is there physical evidence of
something in the car because that that
would lead you to believe that there's
some sort of physical evidence maybe
there's data in the car it looked like a
ford escape or something like that
so i call the friend that owns a ford
escape and i'm like hey does your does
your gps track the data does it like
keep that data he's like yeah i think so
it like has the last addresses that i've
used so maybe just maybe
maybe it's hard data in that car's
computer that they're looking for so
they didn't seize the car they seized
the car's computer it just happened to
be in the car
maybe there's something else to it maybe
maybe i'm just off my rocker and the
[ __ ] neighbor had their car out front
and they're like hey that's his car and
the neighbor's like no that's my [ __ ]
car don't don't don't haul away my car
who knows i don't know maybe it's just a
coincidence too that the neighbor
neighbor didn't pay their [ __ ]
speeding tickets so they they towed away
the neighbor's car just it happened to
be in front of derapaska's house at the
time
i don't know i'm just throwing around
ideas i find it very funny though
that they uh that they took the car
that's the best part
that's the best part maybe there's
something in the car i don't know like
uh maybe hunter biden's laptops in the
car i don't know
maybe it was hanging out in there maybe
rudy put it in the car
how are we supposed to know how he's
supposed to know what hunter biden's
laptop's doing
i mean you know hunter biden's laptop's
probably gonna run for president in 2024
and yeah i'm soon hunter biden's laptop
will soon announce its campaign for the
2024 uh presidential race but right now
right now it's hanging out in
derapaska's car
i don't know maybe again maybe rudy put
it in there
for safe keeping
you know
because we know rudy has ties to these
ukrainians
uh the ukrainians are already pleading
guilty in federal cases that rudy
giuliani is involved in he's under
investigation here he's lost his awa his
right to practice law and practically
everywhere
so we have rudy giuliani and then even
paul manafort again he was the he was
the campaign manager for paul manafort
but another another trump person that is
under indictment federal indictment
that has to do with russians you know
russians and trump they always kind of
live on the same [ __ ] page have you
ever noticed that
like when you're reading this story it's
like trump russia trump russia russia
trump russia trump putin trump trump
putin
like over and over and over and over
again constantly constantly constantly
constantly what the [ __ ]
how does this happen
well there's another person that's under
federal indictment that has to do where
trump and russia end up on the same page
of the same story and it's jesse benton
uh and is his co-conspirator doug weed i
believe is his name but you remember
jesse benton you remember him i've
talked about him here on the podcast but
he's the one that he got charged with
bribery charges
because in 2012 he was bribing people to
support ron paul in the iowa primary and
the 2012 campaign
where mitt romney was the nominee
eventually but in the iowa prime primary
and apparently jesse benton was paying
people bribes to support ron paul not
rand paul we're talking about daddy's
[ __ ] bag
not not rand paul half-ass doctor
shitpeg
not not [ __ ] junior i'm talking about
ron paul now
jesse benton has worked for rand paul
too [ __ ] back junior he's also worked
for mitch mcconnell
jesse benton has worked for mitch
mcconnell and jesse benton is the one
that's under federal indictment for
taking a hundred thousand dollars from a
russian and funneling it through the
trump campaign
somehow part of it's missing
and this payment apparently maybe maybe
just maybe the court is alleging that it
was possibly a payment so that way that
russian can meet with donald trump the
campaign
are they excuse me the nominee of the
campaign of 2016 at a fundraiser in in
pennsylvania
which when you think about it jesse
benton and mitch mcconnell jesse ben's
worked for mitch mcconnell
guess who else has ties guess who else
russia and jesse benton and mitch
mcconnell and donald trump all end up on
the same page of the same story
daraposka
he has ties to mitch mcconnell it's kind
of funny how all these people end up on
the same page of the same story in the
same [ __ ] book
isn't it
is it just that [ __ ] convenient
no it is not that [ __ ] convenient
it's not that [ __ ] convenient
it can't be
that we have jesse benton who who who is
under federal indictment for receiving a
hundred thousand dollars funneling it
through the 2016 trump campaign
for a russian
who who jesse benton has worked for
mitch mcconnell in the past and then you
have daraposka
this it's again they all end up on the
same story in the same page in the same
[ __ ] book
always
always
and then
the best story we have from this week
the best result we have really honestly
it should have been much faster i
believe their statement should have been
much more stern against sloppy steve
bannon
but here's another character that ends
up on the same pages in the same book in
the same [ __ ] story
mr steves bannon sloppy steve
so last night during a special hearing
of the january 6 select committee
uh benny thompson the chair and the
co-chair liz chaney
lay down the gauntlet on
on steve bannon now i'm a little
disappointed in the tone liz cheney had
a little better tone than thompson i
think thompson really should have had
a much more stern tone but that that's
not benny thompson's personality he's
much more measured than i would be
i'd be on that [ __ ] like stink
on [ __ ]
but liz cheney did a pretty good job of
uh not just eviscerating steve bannon
but also getting on the record and
telling the country that this isn't just
about steve bannon this this contempt
charge isn't just about steve bannon
it's about donald trump and it's about
donald trump being guilty of something
and hiding it
that's i mean i'm i'm putting it in my
words
but we'll listen to her words i got some
clips here that i want to play you i'm
not going to play the whole thing but
i'm going to play a couple clips
from the statements from the chair
representative thompson and liz chaney
and i also want to give you commentary
on liz cheney and why it's important
that we listen to her during this
hearing but we also got to listen to her
with a measured ear
because if anyone believes that liz
cheney is some kind of ally to democracy
here you need to think again
is she an ally against trump absolutely
is she an ally against january 6
absolutely and the reason why is because
it's it's
it's starting to look like it's a death
blow to her party
and her dad darth vader's party and
darth vader jr wants to take over
daddy's party
the old guard the gop not the gqp that
they've turned into
the cult that it has become
and she warns against that
in the hearing
she says
you are [ __ ] liars and you know
you're [ __ ] liars
and you're gonna destroy you're gonna
destroy the possibility of us having a
party if you continue this gqp [ __ ]
which they're going to
they're not going to stop this gqp stuff
this maga trump hump and fascism
they're not going to stop it
i mean we have we have right now we have
uh glen younkin running around virginia
in certain places uh he's trump and
other places he he doesn't even know who
trump is never heard of the guy
you have glen younkin running around
doing that
he's trump younkin is trump so if you're
in virginia go vote for mcauliffe
because if you get younken as your
governor that's what it's going to be as
trump as i'm 24 7.
because younkin's running around in
trump country in virginia acting like
he's trump he's trying to collect that
trump vote so you know you know who's
going to weaponize that trump bone
against yunkan it's going to be donald
trump the cheeto dust mobster is going
to weaponize that vote against him if he
becomes governor
just like he tried to weaponize these uh
uh
his voters and his vote to these state
representatives and these these
secretaries of state
these republican secretaries of state in
georgia and arizona pennsylvania
and this is all part of the january six
stuff that's leading back to steve
bannon in the first place
where we see steve bannon all up in the
january 6 planning not just on his radio
show blasting out what what what his
viewers and his listeners and the maga
trump humpers
and the trumpism army the maga army
these [ __ ] boneheads what they're
supposed to do on january 6 and how
they're supposed to do it jesus christ
they were trumpeting this stuff all
december january 6 january 6 january 6
january 6th they kept on and kept on and
kept on and kept on it steve bannon's in
the war room with with
[ __ ] rudy giuliani when they're
making phone calls to the goddamn
congressmen and the senators saying you
gotta stall you gotta stall you gotta
stall
so he knows he was there and that's kind
of what benny thompson and liz cheney
says in these clips that i'm gonna show
you they knew he knew he knew what was
happening he was part of the planning
and they know
they know
and steve bannon knows that they know
and donald trump knows that they know
now i believe that this slow walk to
this contempt charge is [ __ ]
ridiculous
we definitely should have sped this up a
bit
here we are [ __ ] almost two weeks
past the goddamn deadline
and we're just now gonna get a a vote on
the house floor what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here you don't show up
any other person in the [ __ ] country
would be hauled off in handcuffs with a
[ __ ] warrant they show up at their
[ __ ] house or pull them over in their
car
cuff them and take them to jail
or lean on them till they can't [ __ ]
breathe depending on the color of their
[ __ ] skin
that's what would happen to anyone else
in america
but you have steve bannon here claiming
some stupid [ __ ] executive privilege
that he doesn't have that donald trump
doesn't have
and joe biden has already slammed that
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] trash
you're not getting executive privilege
you don't have it
and not only that so what what steve
manning is saying was executive
privilege and and liz cheney kind of
gets into it
and maybe i should you know what i'll
talk about it after we watch the liz
jenny i'll talk about the executive
privilege and what my view on it is in
my words not liz jenny's in my words you
know the the
the [ __ ] version of the
of the executive privilege
so let's let's go ahead and play the
benny thompson uh benny thompson opened
the
the hearing uh because he is the chair
of the of the committee
and um
he he he does a good job of kind of
saying what i just said where
um you know
steve bannon is he not only does he
think he has executive privilege he
thinks he just has a straight out
privilege of not having to comply with
the subpoena
he just thinks he has a straight out
privilege so let's let's go to
let's go to that clip here
we believe mr bannon has information
relevant to our probe
and we'll use the tools at our disposal
to get that information
i expect that the house will quickly
adopt this referral to the justice
department and that the u.s attorney
will do his duty and prosecute mr bannon
for criminal contempt of congress mr
bannon stands alone in his complete
defiance of our subpoena
that's not acceptable
no one in this country no matter how
wealthy or how powerful is above the law
left unaddressed this defiance may
encourage others
to follow mr bannon
down the same path
for folks watching at home this evening
i want you to think about something
what would happen to you if you did what
mr bannon is doing
if you were a material witness in a
criminal prosecution or some other
lawsuit
what would happen
if you refused to show up
do you think you'd be able to just go
about
your business
we all know the answer to that
there isn't a different set of rules for
mr bannon he knows this
he knows that there are consequences for
outright defiance and he's chosen the
path toward criminal contempt
by taking this position while we don't
know all the facts we do know that there
was a powerful push
to overturn the legitimate results
of the 2020 election the rule of law
remains under attack right now
if there are no accountability for these
abuses
if there are different sets of rules for
different types of people
then our democracy is in serious trouble
so that's a good point there at the end
uh about different sets of rules for
different people
so if you really think about it if steve
bannon is allowed to just get away with
uh not complying with
the subpoena
and he's not held in criminal contempt
of congress and when i mean held in
criminal contempt i mean held
accountable
not just voted on and then goes to the
doj and they [ __ ] bury it in a
goddamn drawer somewhere i'm talking
about they give that son of a [ __ ] the
maximum penalty which apparently is 12
months and a thousand dollar fine the
minimum the absolute minimum that the
doj and the courts will give steve
bannon if they convict him in a trial or
if he pleads guilty is a month in prison
so he'll be in prison they should jail
him until they finish it that's what
they should do is jail him until they
finish it
as soon as doj takes the case goes to
the grand jury and he is indicted
because that's probably what they're
going to do is they're going to use a
grand jury here if it goes to the doj
which it is going to go it's going to
get voted it only needs a simple
majority to go to the doj the department
of justice where more than likely the
the attorney general mayor garland will
make the ultimate decision rather
department of justice is going to pursue
these charges
and they're probably going to use a
grand jury to to indict steve bannon
because they don't want it to appear to
come from a prosecutor they want it to
appear to be non-biased from a grand
jury
grand jury indictments carry much more
weight in most cases especially when you
have the trump chaos machine that's
going to ensue when he's charged
because that's what's going to happen
and what you should do is jail that son
of a [ __ ]
you should jail him the federal judge
that arranged him has the right to not
issue him a bond just like all we see in
all these insurrectionists
they they could they didn't have to
release them with an ankle bracelet out
on their own recondence they they had
the right to jail them and they did jail
a lot of them
they should have jailed more of them
because they were violent especially the
violent ones
but steve bannon should be jailed until
it's when goes to trial that's what
should happen
they should punish him to the fullest
extent of the law that they can
for
criminal contempt of congress because
apparently it's a misdemeanor charge it
isn't actually a felony
i i don't know why a felony of contempt
of congress doesn't exist
if there's a if there's an example of a
contempt of congress felony this is it
where you're trying to overthrow the
constitution the united states when
you're trying to help the cheeto dust
mobster
with a coup an attempted coup
a coup attempt isn't enough to get a
[ __ ] felony
for contempt of congress when you won't
show up and you won't comply with a
subpoena when they're trying to in when
congress is trying to investigate a coup
to overthrow the united states
constitution
where the plan was for a mob to go
murder
nancy pelosi and mike pence
we can't get a [ __ ] felony for
contempt of congress are you [ __ ]
kidding me what the [ __ ]
but they should they should use the long
arm and the hammer of the law and lay it
down on steve bannon [ __ ]
100
full stop full hammer write down on that
son of a [ __ ]
so that's probably the progression but a
grand jury works slow and so does an
arraignment and an indictment work so
cause they're probably gonna seal all
this stuff
which means it's gonna slow walk even
further
until they unseal it for the arraignment
to arraign him
and then the trial will and then the the
discovery and the trial will commence
but until then it sounds like
what benny thompson says
is
they know what happened on january 6th
they know the stuff they want from steve
bannon the reason why i know is because
the evidence exists
and liz cheney talks about it in this
clip that i'm going to play and remember
i want to remind you that i'm playing
these two clips um and you're seeing
them from the live stream that i did
last night of the january 6 committees
live stream on youtube so you can go
over to youtube and watch theirs but i
also got commentary before and after
it's on my youtube channel just go to
thetonymichaels.com or go to youtube
subscribe to the channel the video is
there it should be at the very top
that's the hearing
and the entire hearing is there so if
you want to watch the uh some before and
after and the hearing go check that out
it's only about an hour long but it
features the entire hearing but let's go
to the part i clipped up some stuff from
liz cheney that i thought was important
that i wanted to comment and give my
comments today on on some of the things
she said and i've already said some
things but let's go to the liz uh cheney
video here
let's go there
an invaded and occupied the united
states capitol building
all in an effort to halt the lawful
counting of electoral votes
and reverse the results of the 2020
election
the day before this all occurred on
january 5th
mr bannon publicly professed knowledge
that quote all hell is going to break
loose tomorrow end quote
he forecast that the day would be quote
extraordinarily different
than what most americans expected
he said to his listeners and his viewers
quote
so many people said if i was in a
revolution i would be in washington
well he said this is your time in
history
based on the committee's investigation
it appears that mr bannon had
substantial advanced knowledge of the
plans for january 6th
and likely had an important role in
formulating those plans
mr bannon was in the war room at the
willard on january 6th
he also appears to have detailed
knowledge regarding the president's
efforts to sell millions of americans
the fraud that the election was stolen
so far mr bannon's excuse is that former
president trump wishes to invoke some
form of executive privilege
for a subset of the relevant topics
president trump's direct communications
with mr bannon regarding the planning
for january 6th
more important now
there is no conceivably applicable
privilege that could shield mr bannon
from testimony on all of the many other
topics identified in this committee's
subpoena
mr bannon's and mr trump's privileged
arguments
do however appear to reveal one thing
they suggest that president trump was
personally involved in the planning and
execution of january 6th
and this committee will get to the
bottom of that
truth
justice and our constitution have made
america great
almost every one of my colleagues knows
in your hearts
that what happened on january 6th was
profoundly wrong
you all know
that there is no evidence of widespread
election fraud sufficient to have
changed the results of the election
you all know
that the dominion voting machines were
not corrupted by a foreign power
you know these claims are false
yet former president trump repeats them
almost daily
and he has now urged republicans not to
vote
in 2022 and 2024.
this is a prescription
for national self-destruction
so yes you see there liz cheney says
several different things number one she
comments about the executive privilege
that that steve bannon is claiming that
he has because he had communication with
donald trump
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] sherlock he was
communicating with donald trump that was
a whole [ __ ] point
steve bannon was using his goddamn his
radio show and his podcast to trumpet
out what they [ __ ] wanted to do on
january 6th and what the call the arms
was was [ __ ] giuliani stood on stage
and said trial by combat
and they've been trumpeting this stuff
on his show for for weeks and weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks before january
6th
liz cheney lays it out there hell he was
in the goddamn war room while it was
happening
the war room why it was happening
and they were making phone calls to
representatives and senators we know
that now the evidence is there we got
[ __ ] voicemails from rudy giuliani
who is in the room with steve bannon
so of course steve bannon knows the
planning that happened he has
communications with donald trump and
he's openly [ __ ] admitting it
he's openly admitting it to us that he
had communications with donald trump
about january 6 that's why he's claiming
executive privilege here
that's why
because he actually had communications
because that's the [ __ ]
communications that the select
committees wants because they know it
exists and now he's only proving that it
exists by saying i have executive
privilege because i talked to the
president about january 6th
well there you go there's the evidence
right out in the open
and he's the only one that is apparently
defying these uh openly uh outright
defying these subpoenas uh the other
ones aren't exactly they're negotiating
uh what documents when and where and the
depositions so uh mark meadows uh
scovino apparently and patel are all
negotiating there's other folks too that
have been subpoenaed that are also
negotiating that are trying to make sure
that they're not ending up the way that
steve bannon's ending up not only ending
up being charged with criminal contempt
but basically admitting in the public
that yes he was communicating with the
cheeto dust mobster about the attempted
cheeto dust kangaroo coup that happened
on january 6th
where they weren't went to murder mike
pence and lawmakers to make sure that to
overthrow the constitution so donald
trump can remain dictator
of maga land
what the [ __ ] is so hard to understand
about that that's not really difficult
again the trump coloring book is really
[ __ ] easy abc or if it's one two
three just connect the [ __ ] dots
and when you connect the dots it spells
guilty
hello
think mcfly think it's not [ __ ]
rocket science here
steve bannon is admitting
admitting that he had communications
with the president united states by
claiming this executive privilege thing
which he doesn't have because he's a
private citizen and donald trump is no
longer the president of the united
states the actual president your daddy
joe biden you [ __ ] maca trump bumpers
your daddy joe biden the president
united states said nope you don't got
the executive privilege on this one
and also joe biden said he goddamn right
they should charge him with contempt of
congress when referring to steve bannon
he said that the other day uh when a
reporter asked about the contempt charge
of steve bannon
full extent of the law
the current president who currently has
executive privilege
you dumb [ __ ]
the one thing no i want to touch on is
liz chaney's indictment of the
republican party
because it feels like to me a lot of
people think liz cheney is an ally
of democrats in the left here and she
we have to be very careful we have to
walk a tightrope here folks
at least china liz cheney is no ally
to per to progress in this country
this is a person who does not want
voting rights she loves voter
suppression laws and the reason why is
because when darth vader jr takes over
the party again and takes it back from
donald trump at least that's her plan
is to become the leader of the
republican party and the only way to win
in the republican party
is to get people not to vote because she
knows
with or without trump with or without
him their ideas [ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that their
[ __ ] ideas [ __ ] suck
and it's hard to win when you got really
shitty [ __ ] ideas it's hard to win
anything dog catcher or anything the
only way to win is to lie
and to cheat and to rig up the vote with
suppression and gerrymandering districts
her dad darth vader knows a lot about
that
and so does she so we have to be very
careful to make her such an ally to
democracy
because i believe
as much as she might be an ally in this
select committee and the fight against
trumpism in this country it doesn't make
her not a fascist
it just makes her a fascist out of power
remember that
because we have a we have a really tight
race which they keep saying it's tight
but let's not make it so [ __ ] tight
because there's one thing we can do to
make sure that this committee
and these politicians rather it be liz
cheney
as a thin veiled fascist acting like she
loves democracy that's on our side on
this one
or it's democrats
the only way that we make sure we hold
them accountable is to win elections we
have to [ __ ] win
if we lose elections we lose power if we
lose power we can't subpoena anyone
you understand that right
and it all starts with every race not
the race that's going to happen next
year
the next race is virginia and yunkan is
trump and he loves trumpism he's running
around the state of virginia selling
trumpism other than the places where
trump doesn't sell very well
that's why he's not campaigning with
that's why he doesn't even want to say
his [ __ ] name junkin doesn't want to
say trump's name because younkin is
trump younkin is trump younkin is trump
go vote for terry mcauliffe if you know
someone in virginia who's a voter call
them talk to them if you can phone bank
somewhere phone bank if you can mail
letters
mail letters whatever you can do go
knock on doors if you're in virginia
get out the vote we have to bury yunkan
trump
trumpkin
in votes just like we buried larry elder
and trumpism in the california recall
that's what has to happen
that has to be the setup for next year
because we can't just stop there
we have to beat yunkan and then we have
to win primaries we have to win
primaries
and then we have to go on to win general
elections because it's going to be a
little more difficult now that they're
gerrymandering a vote since they [ __ ]
up the census and they really try to rig
up the census for everyone
but we have to
have to get out the vote go
[ __ ] vote
go go [ __ ] vote because yunkan is
trump
and if you can't vote in virginia if
you're not a citizen virginia call
someone that you know that's a citizen
go there
go
tell them call them mail them a letter
do some phone banking just like we did
in california because we must pile the
votes on yunkan because we have to bury
trumpism in this country and the only
way to do that is to vote
we can yell and scream and holler
have committees have committee meetings
but we can't if we don't have the right
people in power to do that can you
imagine what would happen to the select
committee
if republicans take the house next year
that's what's at stake
and it starts with every election every
one of them even your local elections
god damn we see all these people showing
up and acting like maniacs at these
school board meetings do you want those
people in charge of school boards too
well
we have to make sure that trumpism
doesn't take hold anywhere
and the next big race is virginia and we
have to not only prove to democrats all
around the country that we can do this
we can keep the house we can expand the
senate it's possible
these people out there in the media
telling you and it's not possible
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
we have the voters
there is 81 million people that are
ready to cast a vote against trumpism
i believe that wholeheartedly i don't
think 81 million people voted for joe
biden i think a big portion of vote for
joe biden but i think a big portion of
them voted against trump
81 million people are out there and
probably more now
now that we have some more people two
years younger people got 18 to register
to vote now
more people are eligible we should
continue to register to register those
people to vote
and we must pile them in votes go
[ __ ] vote that is how we make sure
that steve bannon is held in contempt
that's how we make sure
we hold all these [ __ ] maga trump
bumpers rather they had anything to do
with january 6 or not accountable
but if they had something new with
january 6 we definitely want to hold
them accountable steve bannon rudy
giuliani donald trump donald trump jr
all those [ __ ] dancing in that tent i
posted that today do you remember that
kimray guilfoyle dancing in the tent
they were so [ __ ] excited about
overthrowing the constitution united
states can you imagine being so excited
about overthrowing the
the free world being so excited to
overthrow the constitution united states
be so excited about a mob going and
killing the vice president united states
if he didn't do what the cheeto dust
mobster wanted him to do
can you imagine being so excited they
were
they were [ __ ] elated huh they they
were having a party woohoo it's gonna be
so exciting
they were ready for it
they were geared up for trial by combat
you heard it from rudy giuliani
so let's hope they vote and they move
this forward very quickly with steve
bannon and not only that that they get
the depositions from all these other
people that are getting subpoenaed
and anyone who [ __ ] makes a false
move that they're not that they're going
to defy the subpoena they push forward a
hell of a lot quicker with the contempt
criminal contempt charges than they did
with steve bannon because that was slow
walked i don't give a [ __ ] what anyone
says about process i don't care about
your schedule i don't care about your
process the american people want [ __ ]
results and they want them now
it's it's [ __ ] october it happened in
january
the beginning of january it's time to
[ __ ] get to the bottom of this and
get results
that the american people can see
i have confidence in benny thompson that
he's gonna do that i have confidence i'm
a little upset about the slow walking in
the process here
but i have confidence that he's gonna
get to the bottom of this and we all
should too and the way we should show
our support of that is to go vote
you gotta vote
you have to go
[ __ ] vote hashtag
go vote
go vote and the next election
is is uh the yunkan the yunkan mccall so
go vote for terry mcauliffe in virginia
i'm not endorsing terry mcauliffe i'm
just endorsing anti-trumpism
let's not have trumpism and that's terry
mcauliffe that's good enough for anybody
should be good enough for anybody
because yunkan
is trump
yunkin
is trump
younkin is trump
because you know what [ __ ] fucklin
younkin [ __ ] him
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
em